Hello, everyone.
In one way or another, the spread of COVID-19 is forcing all of us to change our daily routines.
That might mean working from home or it might mean planning how to close your business temporarily.
Many of you are worried about your jobs, about paying the bills or taking care of your kids.
But know that we've got your back.
We've already announced a whole range of measures to protect jobs and the economy.
From new rules on employment insurance to financing for businesses.
And today, we launched a 27-billion-dollar plan to help all Canadians get through these challenging and exceptional times.
Across the country, people like you are reaching out to support each other.
You know we're in this together.
Together, we can make sure that everyone has the support they need.
This isn't an easy time.
But it's going to get better.
And until it does, let's just focus on the steps ahead.
Stay home to protect your health and your family's health,...
...but also to lift the load on our doctors and nurses.
And make sure that you're taking time for yourself to rest and do what you need to stay positive.
For a little while, this will be our new normal...
...and that's okay because we are in it together.